now I would say Toki of crowds cheering  and the rumors are the rumors are Twain  Johnson president 2020 here's the  problem right the brand and which has  been it's been very flattering right  that there's been this really  interesting tick in in public opinion  wanting that happen but the problem is  this guy to my right will completely  sabotage the candidate from the inside  yes I will take you down I don't want it  to happen just because it would make you  that much better than me and I just  don't know because Jessica you'd be a  cheerleader for a drain yes absolutely  have you seen his Instagram yes he's so  nice  and he's always showing gratitude  where am i be prepared to donate to the  campaign  [Applause]  [Music]